Quarto Dashboards is a new
feature that is coming to
Quarto in the 1.4 release.
And it's something that we
really decided to add on the
heels of the most
recent Posit conference.
And so it wasn't originally
on the plan for 1.4,
but we decided to take a little
bit of extra time and see if we
could squeeze it in.
Obviously, the goal of
Quarto Dashboards is pretty simple.
Make it easy
to build compelling interactive
dashboards using R,
Python, Julia, Observable.
And very much
sort of heritage of
flexdashboard. So very much
bring flexdashboard in that
type of experience into Quarto.
Incorporate everything
we've learned,
everything the
company has built,
and try to bring that together into
a really great experience for our users.
Dashboards in Quarto are
pretty straightforward.
They're basically
composed of cards.
So you can think about cards
as just sort of the units--
the atomic units that you're
arranging in a dashboard.
And you arrange those
cards into rows and columns
to lay them out. And then you
can use things like pages,
tabsets, and sidebars to
incorporate more advanced layout,
to incorporate controls and
other things that might need to
appear in the dashboard.
But with those simple
building blocks,
it's actually pretty easy
to build some cool dashboards.
So let's build a simple
dashboard. Let's see if we can
do this. So let's just
start from scratch.
I've got a QMD that
I've got going here.
And I'm just going to start
with the front matter.
My dashboard.
And let's make it
format dashboard.
And then let's just put in
for now, we're going
to explore my lack of
our programming skills.
But let's just put in
a simple static plot to start.
And then let's have a
look at what we get.
And so--
oops. We're not quite fitting
on the screen. Hang on.
Oh. There we go.
And so you can see
now I've gotten--
OK. I guess I've gotten a
little title bar, I've gotten
one big card.
And so you can see the
treatment is already a little
different than just a simple
web page because we're filling
the whole screen. And in fact,
as we add elements to this
dashboard, like let's add a
second plot to this dashboard,
it knows enough to lay
things out appropriately.
So it just made
to two different cards here
and the cards contain
the visualization.
But of course,
I may want to start to do some cooler
things to tune this up a little bit. So
let's start by putting a
title on some of these cards.
So let's go title
cards plot.
And then we'll add
a title down here.
Empty cards
plot.
And we're
starting to see, OK.
Now, we're getting--
it's getting better.
I wonder if those might
look better side by side.
Well, in Quarto Dashboards, you use
headings to arrange things. And so
by adding a simple heading, I
can basically say, OK. I'd like to--
I guess maybe the way to explain
it is to do this. Is to say,
dashboards have sort
of an orientation,
which by default, is rows.
So by default it's saying,
just everything that
shows up is a row.
I could change that
and say, actually like,
let's make everything
columns instead.
And so when I do that,
we'll actually get the
layout now into columns.
Similarly, if I said, let's go
back to rows, just a good old
basic orientation that we had.
If I said, I want to make
a row explicitly, I can add a heading
and say, here's a
row that I made.
And so I made a row and the
row has two things side by side in it.
It'll get even easier to see
if I do something make another row
and put some content
in it. Here is
some content.
So now I have made a dashboard
that basically has here,
a row with some content in it.
And then here a row
with the plots in it.
And you can see that looks
very straightforward.
And so that gives you the
basic idea of arranging things. Now,
you can keep going.
So I could say,
I'm going to make a
column inside here.
And then I'm going to
make another column,
and I will put another
plot inside that column.
So
I'll put another
slot cars in here.
And so you can see,
you can make some pretty
fancy layouts with some pretty simple
constructs with just using
headings to arrange content.
But
maybe
you want to do something
cooler.
So for example, maybe
instead of putting these
side by side like that,
we want to make them in tabs.
So we can just add a tab
set to our column heading right there.
And now we've got them in tabs.
So that's pretty cool.
But maybe we don't
even want them in tabs.
Maybe we want them
on separate pages.
So why don't we put a heading
one right here and we'll make a page
and a page,
page 2.
And now we've arranged them on
completely standalone pages. And in fact,
we could have very fancy layouts
on each of these two pages.
And so you can see that
some important
concepts at work here.
So one important concept is these
code cells are very, very primary.
So these code cells are
automatically making cards.
And so that means you don't
really have to do a lot of
work. You basically can
make code cells that create
visualizations and then place
some simple markdown around the
outside to provide the
layout and orientation.
The second, as you can see,
the headings and the markdown that
you need to add to create
these layouts is really
straightforward and hopefully
very, very intuitive.
So that gives you some of
the basic ideas. Now, of course,
there's more you can do.
You can do things like add
additional navigation. So I could say like
I want a Twitter sharing link
and then I want a
GitHub link to the repo.
And then we'll automatically
do the right thing and figure out your
GitHub URL and put a share in URL.
So you can very quickly get
some pretty nice things.
There are more things you can
do than just cards. So for example,
you could do a row that's
got what are called value boxes.
Value boxes, you probably
are familiar with from bslib.
But if I want to make
a value box here,
I can make a code cell
and then I can just say,
this code cell is a value box.
And then this code cell really just
needs to return a list that describes
what we want to show
here. So let's just say
my
value is 26.
The color is going to be red.
And let's even
put an icon on it
for like envelope.
And then let's make two of those
just because it'll look a little cooler.
So now we've got
a red and a green value
box that we've created.
And there they are. They've
showed up just as you'd expect.
And what's great about this
is now these value boxes,
of course, since they're
built programmatically,
can be responsive.
So obviously, they
can be red and green.
The icons can update to
reflect thing or reflect the status.
And so it's super
straightforward now to make
these types of arrangements
using this Quarto Dashboard.
Now,
I think the other thing to
think about and one other area
that we focused on was trying
to create experiences that were great
inside notebooks as well.
And so here I've got
a Jupyter Notebook.
I was showing you a
Quarto markdown document.
Now I've got a Jupyter Notebook
that's built in a dashboard as well.
And part of what's great about
using the cells as sort of
atomic units,
as you can see, this notebook,
which basically makes
a pretty nice dashboard
has some markdown cells,
but really is just a set of
code cells with a little bit of
markdown around it to arrange
it. And if we actually
open up a terminal here
and actually preview this.
Quarto
review Gapminder.
So if we actually preview
this Jupyter Notebook,
we will--
oops.
We will see, here's the
dashboard that that creates. And so
you can go and
create pretty great authoring experiences
inside notebooks even for building
these really nice and robust
auto dashboards.
And so
I think the last little bit
for me to talk about is
just give you a quick
look, a preview of some interactivity.
So let me just get back to--
so a couple examples
of interactive dashboards.
And so obviously,
the static dashboards that I showed
you help you understand the layout.
But here's a nice dashboard
that shows some of
the interactivity and how straightforward.
It is to incorporate things
like shiny into these dashboards.
So
this is all pretty cool.
But what's really cool is when
you look at the actual source
behind it and you see how
straightforward the source is.
We've made a sidebar,
we have the main plot, we
have the data, the data page.
And then we've just mixed some
code cells in there that create
the various inputs
that actually render the plot.
And all of that works
just beautifully.
And so it's really
straightforward to make both
fancy layouts and also
pretty impressive interactive dashboards.
As I said, this is
coming in Quarto 1.4.
I think we anticipate
that early next year.
And
I wanted to highlight, I
think, one other thing,
which is over the
past two weeks,
we've been working
hard on this feature.
But the rest of the company
has chipped in a great way by
helping us both test
and generate a huge number
of sample dashboards.
We appreciate everyone's
effort and support doing that.
I have found a number of really
great bugs as a result of all
that testing. A few of
which are still open,
but I'm getting through them.
And we also have probably 20
great samples on the Quarto website,
most of which were contributed by
other members of the company. So
thanks to all for
your support as we
grind really hard to try
to get this into Quarto 1.4
unexpectedly. So thanks all and
hopefully people
like what they see. [MUSIC PLAYING]
PLAYING]